Leonardo DiCaprio has been praised as a
critically acclaimed actor from his
roles in Titanic to his oscar-winning
performance in the Revenant but it seems
nowadays he's being praised for his
dancing skills
yeah I know I was confused at first too
but while parting it up in Miami Leah
was caught breaking it down on the dance
floor and uh yeah let's just say the
internet could not get enough the video
in question has now gained over 4.6
million views and Counting and it shows
DiCaprio vibing out at the lounge at
Gecko the South Beach hot post owned by
none other than Bad Bunny
delete delete
so this is amazing Because the Internet
is divided by Leo's low energy slow
motion dance moves I don't know I kind
of dig it it's the little hat tip though
for me kind of seems like he's had a lot
to drink but while we're not sure if
DiCaprio will win an Academy Award for
his dance skills I'm going to say
probably not maybe this viral moment
will give him the encouragement to try
out Dancing with the Stars one can only
hope